bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat l'école parvient-elle encore à
transmettre les valeurs de la République
la question se pose avec une acuité
toute particulière au lendemain des
attentats meurtriers de janvier dernier
dès la fin janvier ici au Sénat à la
demande du groupe UMP une commission
d'enquête a été créée sur le service
public de l'éducation la perte de repère
républicain et les difficultés
rencontrées par les enseignants on parle
ce matin de ce dernier point les
difficultés rencontrées par les
enseignants c'est l'objet des auditions
qui ont eu lieu hier par cette
commission elle entendait deux
enseignants un professeur de philosophie
François Xavier bami et une professeur
de lettres Gabriel deramo également
auteur d'un livre remarqué au titre
quelque peu iconoclaste collège inique
ta mère tous deux reviennent sur les
difficultés rencontrées dans le cadre de
l'exercice de leur métier et tous deux
de insiste sur le fossé qui se creuse
entre la France et une partie de sa
jeunesse on découvre leurs diagnostic et
leurs propositions tout de suite en
audition nous poursuivons notre séance
d'audition en recevant Monsieur François
Xavier béami professeur de philosophie
auteur d'un ouvrage consacré aux
question éducative ancien élève de
l'École normale supérieure vous êtes
professeur agrégé de philosophie depuis
mars 2008 vous exercz aussi des
fonctions électives en tant qu'adjoint
au maire de Versailles délégué à la
jeunesse et à l'enseignement supérieur
parallèlement vous êtes l'auteur de
tribune dans différentes publications
dans le Figaro valeurs actuelles et
libération dans lesquelles vous vous
intéresserz plus particulièrement aux
questions politiques et de société en
2014 vous publiez les déshérités ou
l'urgence de transmettre vous y faites
part de votre étonnement face à la
formation que vous avez reçu et où la
transmission des savoirs est présentée
comme une violence faite aux élèves la
commission d'enquête a souhaité vous
entendre pour que vous puissiez à la
lumière de votre expérience d'enseignant
et de spécialistes des questions
éducatives présenteer votre analyse les
difficultés de l'école et les manières
d'articuler ces différentes missions de
l'école qui consiste en même temps à
éduquer à la citoyenneté et instruire
pour vous quelle mesure urgente devrait
être mise en place pour redonner à
l'école sa fonction
intégratrice comme le bureau de la
commission d'enquête l'a décidé cette
audition sera captée et diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
elle fera également l'objet d'un
compterendu publié dans le recueil des
travaux de commission accessible en
version papier et sur le site internet
du Sénat avant de vous passer la parole
le formalisme des commissions d'enquête
me conduit à vous demander de prêter
serment je suis également tenu de vous
indiquer que tout faux témoignage devant
notre commission serait pas cible des
peines prévues aux articles 43413 à
43415 du code pénal en conséquent je
vous invite à prêter serement de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levez
la main droit et dit je le jure je le
jure je vous remercie selon l'usage
habituel je vous propose de nous faire
part de vos observations durant une
dizaine de minutes après quoi notre
rapporteur Jacques groperin et les
membres de la commission qui le
souhaitent pourront vous poser leurs
questions je vous laisse la parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord je vous remercie
infiniment de votre invitation qui me
touche beaucoup vous avez mentionné mon
expérience d'enseignant elle est à la
vérité bien modeste car je suis un tout
jeune enseignant mais je voudrais auprès
de vous ce matin me faire si c'est
possible le porte-parole et peut-être le
relais de l'expérience de nombre de mes
collègues vous en recevrez certainement
bien d'autres pour témoigner de ces
difficultés que nous rencontrons
peut-être quotidiennement en tous les
cas de manière régulière dans l'exercice
de notre métier et qui font partie de
l'intitulé même de votre commission ces
difficultés en fait ne sont pas
étonnantes et c'est de là que je
commencerai il est même étonnant que
nous nous en étonnions car nous les
avons peut-être découvertes il y a
peut-être eu une prise de conscience à
l'occasion des événements dramatiques
qui ont marqué notre pays au début de ce
mois de janvier dernier une prise de
conscience de l'étendue de la distance
qui s'est créée entre la France et une
partie de sa jeunesse entre nos
institutions et une partie de la
population française une prise de
conscience que beaucoup d'enseignants
beaucoup de mes collègues ont vécu dans
la douleur en voyant leurs élèves
incapables d'un dialogue avec eux
capable de conserver un dialogue avec la
République incapable de partager ces
repères et ces principes qui font la vie
en société qui la structure et qui la
protège mais à la vérité il est étonnant
que nous nous étonnions car le
diagnostic nous le connaissons déjà
parfaitement et nous le connaissions
déjà parfaitement permettez-moi de
rappeler simplement quelques éléments
chiffrés on ne me soupçonnera pas de
faux témoignages puisque je les
empreinte pour leur totalité au
statistiqu publié par le le gouvernement
ou par des organes de l'État ou des
institutions internationales la dernière
enquête PISA publiée en 2013 constatait
que 22 % des collégiens en classe de 5e
doivent être considérés comme en
situation d'échec et comme je cite la
formule de l'enquête PISA incapable de
participer de manière active et efficace
à la vie de la société en classe de 5e
un collégien sur 5 était donc considéré
comme en situation d'échec
grave une enquête publiée par la
direction de la prospective et de la
performance de l'éducation nationale
constatz que des élèves de 3e un élève
sur 5 soit 20 % sont incapables de
donner un sens à une information et de
décrypter un texte même simple comment
s'étonner ensuite quand nous voyons que
parmi nos élèves un grand nombre sont
incapables de prendre la de la distance
par rapport aux images publiées sur
internet comment s'étonner que cette
distance critique devienne difficile
lorsque nous savons pertinent
d'après nos propres statistiques que nos
élèves de 3e sont marqués par cette
difficulté à décrypter un texte même
simple et à donner un sens à une
information enfin dernière statistique
dernière statistique c'est celle que
peut-être nous connaissons le mieux et
dont nous parlons le moins et celle qui
me paraît sans doute la plus dramatique
celle qui chaque année à l'occasion des
Journées de défense et de citoyenneté
mesure l'ilétrisme dans notre pays comme
vous le savez chaque année bon an Malan
entre 18 et 20 % des jeunes Français en
additionnant les classes de statistique
doivent être considérés comme dans une
situation de grande difficulté pour
réussir un exercice qui consiste à
déchiffrer un programme de cinéma entre
18 et 20 % des jeunes Français à leur
majorité ont du mal à dire à partir d'un
programme de cinéma quel acteur joue
dans quel film à quelle heure est elle
production et comment on se rend dans la
salle qui permet de visionner telle ou
telle représentation comment s'étonner
encore ensuite comment s'étonner que
nous soyons devant une telle difficulté
une telle distance comment s'étonner que
nous ayons abandonné ces collégiens ces
lycéens qui sortent de nos
établissements scolaires à la rapidité à
la superficialité à la facilité des
discours simplistes auquel ils peuvent
être exposés sur Internet et notamment à
cette puissance de l'image devant
laquelle aucune distance n'est plus
possible quand nous n'avons plus
l'expérience du texte de la lecture et
du déchiffrage qu'il
permet une dernière mention qui est
celle peut-être qui me blesse le plus
comme enseignant qui qui je pense fait
le plus souffrir les enseignants dans
l'exercice de leur métier c'est celle
qui là encore nous a été infligée par la
dernière enquête PISA en 2013 et qui
nous a révélé que notre système scolaire
français était devenu le plus
inégalitaire des pays de l'OCDE celui où
le poids de l'origine sociale joue le
plus par conséquent bien souvent je
crois nous pouvons nous rassurer lorsque
nos enfants ou les enfants que nous
connaissons sont dans des établissements
qui fonctionnent encore car oui l'école
n'est pas en situation de faillite
unilatérale oui le système éducatif
français n'est pas en situation d'échec
partout et nous connaissons et par
exemple dans la ville dans laquelle je
suis élu nous connaissons évidemment des
établissements scolaires qui
fonctionnent remarquablement bien nous
savons que les enseignants sont dévoués
à leur métier qu'ils se donnent à leur
métier nous savons que beaucoup d'écoles
réussissent ce miracle qui consiste à
transmettre le savoir et la connaissance
mais dans bien des lieux dans bien des
endroits et notamment dans tous les
endroits où les familles ne veillent pas
où les familles d'une certaine façon
même n'exercent pas une attention
vigilante une exigence sur le système
scolaire auquel ils confient leurs
enfants dans bien dans bien des lieux
c'est vrai nous avons abandonné nos
enfants nous avons abandonné nos élèves
à la facilité de ces discours à la
superficial à la superficialité de ces
discours et à la tentation de la
violence et il est étonnant que nous
nous en étonnions aujourd'hui car tout
cela nous le savions bien avant Charlie
hebbdo tout cela nous le savions bien
avant de constater la difficulté que
nous avons à parler à nos élèves la
difficulté que nous avons à récupérer la
confiance de nos élèves quand ils sont
soumis à la pression du numérique et
quand dans le numérique ils trouvent non
pas seulement une technologie
d'information mais aussi bien souvent
une technologie de désinformation devant
laquelle ils sont démunis et privés de
toute capacité d'esprit critique de tout
cela je le crois profondément et
pardonnez-moi si mon propos est
peut-être un peu un peu dur ce matin
mais de tout cela je crois que nous
sommes absolument responsables nous en
sommes responsables et nous l'avons
d'une certaine façon organisé vous avez
mentionné madame la Présidente ce petit
ESS que j'ai publié à la rentrée
dernière et qui s'appelle les dshérités
ce petit essai est tout simple et très
humble il est né d'un étonnement c'est
vrai de l'étonnement que j'ai ressenti
comme jeune enseignant lorsque arrivant
dans notre année de formation à l'IUFM
avec tous les collègues qui partager
avec moi cette expérience nous avons vu
notre formation tout au long de cette
année d'ufm structurée par un principe
fondamental vous ne devez pas
transmettre un savoir c'était la norme
qui nous était proposée c'était le
principe que nous dev devions suivre
d'ailleurs principe qu'il nous fallait
suivre et qui nous était non pas
simplement recommandé ou proposé mais
imposé avec avec toute la la l'autorité
que que que cette institution pouvait
avoir sur nous naturellement autorité
d'ailleurs parfaitement légitime mais je
crois le principe pour le coup posait un
problème décisif nous avions appris des
connaissances nous avions suivi des
formations pour pouvoir partager ce
savoir qui nous est commun et on nous
présentait l'acte de la transmission du
savoir comme une violence comme une
brutalité exercé sur nos élèves comme un
acte qui ferait peser sur eux la
condescendance d'une culture qui
s'imposerait à eux et qui les
empêcheraiit d'être même qui les
empêcherait d'être libre peut-être ce
discours était-il animé des meilleures
intentions et je ne condamne pas ceux
qui l'ont tenu et je trouverais
regrettable et tragique d'ailleurs que
le débat éducatif soit réduit à une
espèce de suspicion mutuelle portée d'un
camp contre un autre je crois qu'au fond
nous partageons tous comme adultes une
même générosité et le même désir de voir
nos élèves et nos enfants grandir dans
une authentique liberté et dans une
authentique humanité ce discours était
donc d'une véritable générosité il
consistait à penser que l'autorité de
l'adulte était une privation exercée
contre la liberté de l'enfant il
consistait à penser que tout ce qui est
donné à la transmission est enlevé à la
liberté ce discours était animé par une
vraie générosité au départ mais au fond
la faute morale car il y a une faute
morale vient lorsque constatant l'échec
de ce principe nous avons été incapable
de le remettre en cause comment se
fait-il par exemple que nous sachions si
bien mesurer l'ilétrisme dans notre pays
et que nous soyons incapable de nous
poser la question d'une véritable
amélioration des méthodes d'enseignement
de la lecture l'écart entre ce que nous
savons être le réel et notre capacité de
réagir au problèmes que nous rencontrons
l'écart entre ce que nous savons tous
devoir faire et ce que nous faisons
effectivement voilà ce qui constitue je
crois le véritable scandale éducatif
auquel nous sommes arrivé et dont les
événements tragiques de Charlie Hebdo
ont été un révélateur brutal pour nous
car ces événements sont la conséquence
de notre échec ce qui a je crois le plus
traumatisé les Français dans l'épisode
que nous avons vécu c'est que nous
n'avons pas à faire comme dans une
guerre on a beaucoup parlé de guerre
nous n'avons pas à faaire comme dans une
guerre à une agression qui viendrait de
l'extérieur nous n'avons pas AFF faaire
à une violence qui nous serait infligée
de l'extérieur de nos frontière ce à
quoi nous avons affaire c'est à la
situation de ces jeunes Français qui ont
quitté volontairement la République qui
ont quitté volontairement la communauté
nationale jusqu'à exercer contre leurs
propres concitoyens une violence
inexplicable une violence injustifiable
une violence absolument barbare voilà ce
qui peut-être nous tétanise le plus
voilà ce qui nous terrorise le plus
c'est de voir que ces jeunes Français
avaient tous en commun d'avoir suivi la
totalité du système scolaire en France
d'avoir fait la totalité de leurs études
en France d'avoir suivi la totalité de
ce parcours républiain que nous
voudrions d'intégration et qui est en
fait de désintégration nous n'avons pas
de raison de nous en étonner et je
terminerai par là nous avons expliquer
aux enseignants et les enseignants ont
été expliqués à leurs élèves que
l'histoire française était coloniale que
la langue française était sexiste qu'il
fallait déconstruire la culture comme
étant porteuse de stéréotype nous avons
expliqué à nos élèves que le savoir
était un poids qu'on leur infligeait
nous avons expliqué à nos élèves que la
culture les empêchait de rester naturel
et c'est ainsi que les enseignants
eux-mêmes ont ét amené à concevoir leur
propre métier comme une forme de
malédiction peut-être de malédiction
nécessaire mais de malédiction quand
même nous avons expliqué que la notation
par exemple était une brutalité et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous cherchons
une évaluation bienveillante qui serait
l'évaluation sans note ce qui implique
nécessairement que la notation soit
violence que la notation soit coercition
et nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui
nécessairement démuni devant cette
désintégration que nous avons je le
crois personnellement que nous avons
nous-mêmes organisé peut-être encore
encore une fois avec les meilleures
intentions du monde mon propos ici n'est
pas de porter un jugement ou d'organiser
un tribunal mais d'appeler à une prise
de conscience collective qui commence
peut-être c'est vrai par un examen de
conscience nous avons je crois à
reconsidérer la nécessité de
reconstruire une école qui soit centré
sur sa mission propre la transmission du
savoir la transmission de la culture et
peut-être vous me demandiez si j'aurais
une piste de réflexion pour refonder
cette école que nous appelons de nos
vœux je crois qu'au fond la réforme de
l'éducation nationale n'est pas une
chose très compliquée je crois que la
réforme de notre système scolaire n'est
pas une chose très compliquée nous avons
d'ailleurs dans l'histoire dans notre
histoire la trace d'un système scolaire
qui a fonctionné qui a réussi ce miracle
de constituer l'unité de notre pays au
moment où la France était divisée
explosé éclaté en groupes divers éclaté
en traditions religieuses parfois
violemment opposé au moment où la France
était divisée en patoi et en langue qui
ne se comprenaient pas qui ne se
comprenait plus notre école a réussi à
faire l'unité de la France nous en
sommes donc capables et les enseignants
qui aujourd'hui dans nos établissements
scolaires se dévouent à la tâche
éducative n'attendent n'attendent
peut-être que cela qu'on leur dise que
le savoir qu'ils ont reçu et qu'ils ont
envie de partager autour d'eux que ce
savoirlà est condition de toute
éducation le grand paradoxe qui préside
à la mobilisation de l'école en faveur
des valeurs de la République c'est que
cette mobilisation se fait pour n'avoir
pas su transmettre avec une forme de
coercition redoublée
les cours de morale laïque ne
fonctionneront jamais imposer des
valeurs ne fonctionnera jamais et nous
n'arriverons jamais à construire une
école qui pour n'avoir pas su former
voudrait désormais formater cela ne
fonctionnera pas cela ne peut susciter
que rétisence que résistance et que 10
solutions plus fortes encore et plus
vives encore de la communauté nationale
en revanche si nous savons à nouveau
structurer l'école autour de sa mission
fondamentale transmettre le savoir
transmettre la culture alors oui nous
pouvons car la culture est principe de
toute humanité et de toute liberté nous
pouvons à nouveau construire une école
qui éduquera parce qu'elle sera à
nouveau instruire je ne crois pas au
conflit entre instruction et éducation
je ne crois pas qu'il faille opposer ces
deux tâches l'école peut téduquer mais
elle peut t éduquer si elle sait
instruire et l'instruction est le moyen
et même le seul moyen par lequel nous
pouvons reconstruire une école qui à la
fois reconstruisent notre société et qui
en même temps ouvre chacun de ses
citoyens à une authentique liberté je
vous
remercie merci à vous pour ce propos
dynamique carré donc monsieur le
rapporteur il vous reste la première
salve de questions mais il y a déjà des
réponses je crois dans dans cette dans
ce propos
liminire
question écoutez merci aussi pour cette
fraîcheur enthousiaste et puis réaliste
qui me qui qui me séduit je crois qu'il
doit séduire no sénateur parce que je
crois que nous avons été souvent dans le
déniis et enfin peut-être entendre aussi
un un nouvel
enseignant
venir nous dire des des des points en
tout cas préciser des points avec autant
de autant d'ardeur je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui est qui peut
rafraîchir notre institution mais aussi
peut-être nous ouvrir d'autres d'autres
questions alors moi j'aurais j'aimerais
rebondir sur le sur le savoir et sur la
culture et sur le sur l'instruction la
première question c'est pensez-vous que
la consolidation des savoirs
fondamentaux pour peut participer à la
transmission des valeurs républicaines
alors vous vous êtes professeur de de
philosophie mais mais il y a d'autres
types d'enseignement qui sont à ce jour
remis en question souvent par aussi une
partie de la population qui sont
l'histoire les sciences de la vie de la
terre le français je pense qu'elles
peuvent aussi contribuer à cet objectif
là la deuxème question c'est est-ce que
l'école pour vous doit être être le le
vecteur des valeurs républicaines avec
en figrane le rôle des parents et
comment donner à l'école et aux
enseignants les moyens de mieux
former les citoyens et puis enfin une
dernière question plus généralement on
aime bien avoir quelques préconisations
quelles seraient pour vous les mesures
qui pourrai être mises en place pour
lutter contre ces pertes de valeur et
puis cette esprit républicain peut-être
à retrouver
merci vous voulez répondre
merci beaucoup pour ces trois questions
qui en fait je crois peut-être n'en font
qu'une dans dans la dans la complexité
du problème auquel nous avons à faire
face et en même temps paradoxalement
dans dans sa simplicité l'école
demandez-vous doit-elle être le vecteur
des valeurs républicaines je le crois
personnellement et je dirais même de
façon plus large encore que l'école est
ce par quoi se fonde toute cité d'une
manière générale ce par quoi se fonde
toute chos publique toute République il
n'y a pas de République sans école il
n'y a pas même de politique sans école
au sens où il n'y a pas de cité sans
école qu'est-ce qu'au fond un citoyen
comment former des citoyens Aristote
dans les politiques pardonnez-moi de
passer par des formations
professionnelles la discipline qui m'est
familière Aristote dans les politiques
affirme que le propre du citoyen c'est
de parler avec les autres et le propre
de la cité c'est de parler ensemble de
ce qui est bon et de ce qui est juste
d'entretenir un dialogue commun
d'entretenir ensemble un débat pour cela
encore faut-il savoir parler et encore
faut-il parler la même langue il n'y a
pas de politique quand il n'y a pas de
possibilité de parler ensemble avec la
même langue d'articuler ensemble avec
des mots qui nous permettent de
raisonner communément de raisonner en
commun il n'est pas de politique quand
il n'est pas de transmission efficace
d'une langue commune voyez je crois que
si l'école peut former les citoyens de
demain c'est d'abord peut-être en leur
transmettant cette langue commune non
pas seulement au sens de la capacité de
parler non pas seulement au sens de la
capacité de maîtriser un vocabulaire si
déjà nous pouvions nous accorder sur cet
objectif ce serait là un grand pas fait
en avant mais au sens même de la
capacité de parler ensemble avec le fond
culturel qui nous soit commun de ce qui
est bon et de ce qui est juste et voilà
déjà ce qui me paraît décisif tout à
l'heure monsieur Slama disait que
lorsqu'on a plus les mots naît la
violence c'est vrai dans notre
expérience personnel c'est vrai dans
notre expérience au sens psychique et
psychologique du terme dans notre
expérience intérieure et c'est là
l'exemple preneit monsieur Slama mais
c'est vrai aussi dans notre expérience
collective lorsque nous n'avons plus les
mots pour parler ensemble alors nous
sommes tentés de régler nos différents
par la violence lorsqu'il n'y a plus de
dialogue commun lorsqu'il n'y a plus de
possibilité même d'un dialogue parce
qu'il n'y a plus de langue commune alors
n'est la violence qui remplace la
république c'est quand la République se
défait c'est quand la société se dissou
que la violence semble se rappeler à
nous et de ce point de vue-là il est là
encore étonnant que nous nous en
étonnions lorsque lorsque la culture
n'est plus transmise lorsqu'on a
condamné comme coupable la transmission
de la culture il est étonnant qu'on voit
ressurgir l'autre de la culture
c'est-à-dire la barbarie la barbarie
comme vous le savez désigne dans son
étymologie grecque le le fait de ne pas
pouvoir articuler les mots Barbaros
désignait les mots inarticulés les sons
inarticulés qui sortent de la langue de
celui qui n'a pas reçu la langue commune
qui n'a pas reçu une langue articulée et
bien la barbarie me semble-t-il c'est ce
CR inarticulé qui jaillit d'une
génération ou d'une partie d'une
génération à qui nous n'avons pas
transmis les mots pour participer à la
vie citoyenne à la vie de la cité et de
ce point de vue-l je voudrais dire que
enfin comme enseignant pour rentrer
maintenant dans le dans la dimension
concrète de l'expérience j'ai eu la
chance comme teser vous le savez la
plupart des jeunes enseignants sont
pendant quelques années remplaçants
titulaires sur zone de remplacement j'ai
eu la chance de découvrir un grand
nombre d'établissements j'ai rencontré
des élèves passionnants avec comme tous
les jeunes de notre temps comme tous les
jeunes de toute génération une grande
générosité une grande intelligence une
créativité extraordinaire mais j'ai
rencontré aussi et c'est vrai dans les
zones les plus défavorisées des jeunes à
qui on avait pas transmis les moyens
d'accomplir cette créativité d'accomplir
cette générosité ce désir de se donner
et j'ai rencontré dans ces dans ces
lieux dans ces lycées des jeunes dont je
me suis souvent dit qu'on ne leur avait
pas transmis les moyens de participer
d'une manière productive et active comme
le disait l'enquête PISA à la vie de la
Société des jeune à qui on n même pas
donné les moyens de participer à la vie
de la cité demain et il y a de ce point
de vue-l je crois une grande inquiétude
à avoir en tous les cas nous devons nous
sentir responsable de ces jeunes qui ont
parfois quitté le système scolaire avant
la fin de leur parcours parfois même
l'ont suivi jusqu'au bout mais qui n'ont
pas forcément reçu ces conditions
fondamentales que sont la capacité de
parler d'articuler un raisonnement
conditions fondamentales pour participer
à la vie de la cité pour comprendre les
enjeux d'une élection pour comprendre la
possibilité de la participation
citoyenne et pour prendre leur rôle
comme électeur ou comme élu à la vie de
la cité l'école doit être le vecteur des
valeurs républicaines je dirais d'une
manière plus fondamental encore que
l'école est ce par quoi se prépare toute
République et qu'il n'y a pas de
République sans école mais comment y
parvenir je crois voyez encore une fois
fondamentalement que on n'y parviendra
pas si l'école se trouve mise au service
d'une éducation qui se passerait de
l'instruction c'est là encore une fois
le grand paradoxe et celui qui m'étonne
beaucoup on a le sentiment parfois
pardonnez-moi ce propos peut-être un peu
irrévérencieux mais on a le sentiment
parfois que les responsables politiques
qui produisent les directives n'ont plus
ou pas beaucoup l'occasion d'être en
contact avec des jeunes avec des enfants
avec des adolescents qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup l'occasion d'être en contact
avec des élèves l'idée qu'on pourrait
transmettre des valeurs qui s'imposerait
d'elle-même cette idéelà pardonnez-moi
est une espèce de de une espèce de
fiction ça ne se produit pas et
précisément nous le savons très bien
nous qui par ailleurs sommes capables
d'encourager chez nos élèves l'esprit
critique et de vouloir qu'il développe
un esprit critique parfaitement légitime
par conséquent aucune valeur ne s'impose
d'elle-même aucun principe ne s'impose
de lui-même vous pouvez rentrer en
classe et dire à des enfants dire à des
adolescent qu'il faut refuser tel ou tel
comportement qu'il faut adopter telle ou
telle pratique ça ne s'impose pas de soi
pourquoi faudrait-il être tolérant
plutôt qu'intolérant pourquoi
faudrait-il être respectueux plutôt
qu'irrespectueux pourquoi faudrait-il
être paisible plutôt qu'être violent ça
ne s'impose pas de soi-même je prendrai
un exemple qui m'a personnellement
beaucoup marqué dans ma dans dans dans
mon itinéraire d'enseignant l'exemple du
sexisme on nous dit l'école doit lutter
contre le sexisme ceci fait partie de
ces missions fondamentales comme tout
enseignant j'ai lu avec attention la
lettre que Vincent payon écrivait aux
enseignant au début du dernier quinquena
et et parmi les les consignes les
directives qui étaient proposées aux
enseignants dans une lettre de quatre
pages sur l'émission de l'école figurait
la lutte contre le sexisme c'était une
lettre de quatre pages qui parlait d'un
très grand nombre d'objectifs et qui
mentionnait c'est là d'ailleurs le grand
paradoxe c'est qu'on demande aux
enseignants de faire un peu tout ce que
la société n'arrive plus à faire et donc
qui donnait aux enseignants un très très
grand nombre de de mission il faut que
l'école lutte contre le sexisme pour ma
part j'en suis convaincu je je ne je je
n'affirme pas du tout que cet objectif
soit superflu ni non plus qu'il soit
irréaliste je pense que l'école doit
lutter contre le sexisme c'est même une
priorité qui me paraît effectivement
décisive car je l'ai vu dans beaucoup
d'établissements le sexisme est une
réalité dans beaucoup d'établissements
en particulier dans beaucoup
d'établissements défavorisés la relation
entre les garçons et les filles entre
les jeunes hommes et les jeunes femmes
est une relation marquée parfois par une
très grande violence la façon dont les
garçons parlent fill les comportements
les vocabulaires les attitudes sont
parfois extraordinairement
condescendantes extrêmement violentes et
j'ai vu beaucoup de jeunes filles
souffrir de cette situation il suffit de
considérer les productions de ce qu'il
est convenu d'appeler les cultures
urbaines par exemple certaines certaines
production pas toutes évidemment mais
certaines productions contemporaines
pour constater que l'image de la femme y
est souvent dégradée que l'image de la
femme y est souvent mal trraité et dans
notre espace public d'ailleurs dans
notre société nous devons reconnaître
que même d'ailleurs à travers la
publicité même euh voilà que que que que
le sexisme est bien souvent que la
dévalorisation de la femme est bien
souvent une réalité alors comment
l'école peut-elle lutter contre le
sexisme et bien nous employons une voix
que je crois irréaliste et absurde nous
organisons des ateliers contre le
sexisme des ateliers pédagogiques
éducatifs ludique nous entreprenons
précisément des cours de moral laïque
dans lesquels nous expliquons que le
sexisme c'est mal qu'il ne faut pas être
sexiste et que il ne faut pas mal
traiter les jeunes filles ni mal leur
parler mais ça ne s'impose pas de
soi-même et les adolescents nous
regardent avec une forme de distance
ironique lorsque nous prétendons euh les
réunir dans les cours de récréation pour
pousser un cri contre le sexisme ou bien
lorsque tentant précisément de singer
euh ces cultures qui leur sont
familières nous organisons des des
productions culturelles souvent de
mauvaises qualité euh qui ont pour but
de montrer comme par une sorte de morale
un peu poussive que le sexisme c'est pas
bien bon ça ne marche pas c'est évident
que ça ne marche pas comment l'école
peut-elle lutter contre le sexisme et
bien c'est très simple si ce qui n'est
plus le cas aujourd'hui
si nos si si nos écoliers si nos élèves
si nos étudiants avaient tous une fois
dans leur itinéraire scolaire entendu
parler je sais pas par exemple entendu
parler de la figure de Jean d'c et si on
leur avait fait lire quelques pages du
procès de Jean d'c quand vous avez lu
quelques pages du procès de Jean d'c que
vous soyez chrétien ou non et même quand
vous êtes musulman quand vous avez lu
quelques pages du procès Jean d'c vous
ne pouvez plus considérer que les femmes
sont inférieures aux hommes c'est
impossible impossible vous avez la
démonstration vous avez la preuve vous
avez l'expérience de l'égalité absolu
entre les femmes et les hommes et même
de cette capacité qu'une jeune fille de
19 ans a eu un jour d'humilier une
assemblée d'hommes beaucoup plus savants
et beaucoup plus docte qu'elle si en
physique on réapprenait un peu les
éléments fondamentaux de la connaissance
de la physique et qu'on apprenait à
parler par exemple de ce que je sais pas
une femme comme Marie Cury a apporté à
la connaissance de la physique à la
connaissance de la matière comment
voulez-vous penser que les femmes sont
moins intelligentes que les hommes quand
vous avez compris un peu de la physique
quand vous vous êtes un peu émerveillé
de ce que Marie Cury vous avait permis
de comprendre de ce qui est la matière
si et si chose extraordinaire si par
miracle nos élèves avaient l'occasion de
temps en temps de réapprendre par cœur
un peu de notre poésie française quand
vous avez appris un peu de ronçard un
peu de Verline un peu de Musset un peu
de chaigier comment voulez-vous mal
parler à une fille comment voulez-vous
ensuite traiter une jeune fille
maltraiter une jeune fille de cette
manière absurde et dérisoire qui se qui
qui se fait jour précisément lorsque la
culture s'est effondrée évidemment et
c'est une chose très importante nous ne
pouvons pas non plus idolâtrer la
culture l'homme le plus cultivé du monde
est capable d'être lâche et capable
d'être méchant et capable d'être violent
et capable de faire le mal et nous le
savons très bien l'homme le plus cultivé
du monde et le peuple le plus cultivé du
monde sont capables d'être barbares et
de la manière la plus atroce qu'il soit
c'est vrai la culture n'empêche pas
l'homme d'être inhumain mais l'inculture
empêche assurément les hommes d'êtes
complètement humains et c'est exactement
ce qui se produit dans l'effondrement du
vocabulaire commun dans l'effondrement
de la culture commune c'est ce qui se
produit dans l'effondrement de la
culture cette espèce de barbarie qui
consiste en permanence à rabaisser les
jeunes filles à ne se rapporter aux
autres à ne se rapporter à l'autre que
sous la forme de la violence et d'une
violence absurde d'une violence
déraisonnée d'une violence complètement
gratuite cette violence là je crois nous
la guérirons non pas en organisant des
ateliers contre le sexisme mais tout
simplement en reconcentrant l'école sur
sa mission fondamental transmettre le
meilleur de notre culture transmettre le
savoir et encore une fois je le crois
profondément voyez cette pratique par
exemple encore une fois arrêtons-nous
là-dessus cette pratique du par cœur que
nous avons banni de notre école la
pratique de la mémoire la culture de la
mémoire l'effort même de la mémoire qui
consiste à absorber et à se laisser
l'expression est magnifique à se laisser
transformer par le cœur par les textes
que l'on reçoit cette pratique là toute
simple qui est la mission fondamentale
de l'école transmettre un savoir
transmettre à chaque enfant
participer permettre à chaque enfant de
participer par la mémoire à une culture
qui nous est commune et bien cette Pr
pratique là je crois en la réhabilitant
nous pourrions en faire l'occasion de
lutter contre le sexisme mais aussi
contre toutes les dérives que nous
voyons surgir aujourd'hui j'espère vous
avoir montré à travers ce tout petit
exemple comment l'école peut servir ce
que nous appelons les valeurs de la
République et qui sont en fait en
réalité ce qui constittuent les élément
d'une forme de morale commune d'une
d'une approche commune de ce qu'il de ce
qu'il est vraiment humain de faire et
d'une manière vraiment humaine de se
rapporter à l'autre voilà comment
l'école pourrait contribuer à humaniser
les hommes et à humaniser ces enfants
qui nous sont confiés
dans les salles de classe qui sont les
nôtres merci beaucoup quelques questions
tout d'abord monsieur
Kenel oui madame la
Présidente tout d'abord bravo pour la
fluidité de de votre verbe en 50 minutes
vos élèves doivent en
subir je voulais je voulais vous dire
que ça fait longtemps que j'ai cessé de
m'étonner par contre je m'érite de plus
en plus de plus en plus parce
que je me rends compte que finalement et
pardonnez-moi d'utiliser un peu la la
terminologie médicale
mais finalement diagnostique est posé et
depuis bien longtemps et je crois que
nous sommes tous d'accord sur le
diagnostic le remède est connu me
semble-t-il également par contre la
paologie elle finalement fait défaut
dans tout ce que vous avez dit et
effectivement la lecture du procès de
jeanarc est très instructif en quore
faut-il savoir lire et le problème on en
revient toujours à la base la base c'est
quoi c'est pas tout ce qu'on demande à
l'éducation nationale la base c'est
quand même comment faire pour que
l'ensemble des jeunes puissent y accéder
et là j'aimerais bien vous entendre
là-dessus Carl une autre question merci
Madame le présidente d'abord euh moi
j'ai été ravi d'entendre ce ces propos à
la fois très réaliste rafraîchissant
passionné finalement à partir d'un
constat qui est celui qu'on connaît
plein d'optimistes et vous avez dit
quelque chose moi qui qui me si tout à
fait l'école peut éduquer si elle sait
instruire est-ce que ça devrait pas être
finalement à l'étape de la loi des
nouvelles ESP c'est ça les écoles
supérieures de de de de formation des
professeurs
oui je je rejoins pour ma part la
première
question je voudrais moi vous poser la
question de
qui vous partagez absolument tous les
points de vue que Benois
péistrandi a commis et a écrit dans dans
plusieurs tribunes du monde du figarco
et cetera et où il disait que il y avait
justement une confusion qu'il n'y ait
plus de
transmission mais que on s'occupait
tellement des
inégalités
sociales qu'il fallait en créant
justement ces fameux atelier et qu'il
fallait reprendre la
transmission
et donc je suis en tout cas pour ma part
heureuse de voir qu'il y a ces deux
enseignants qui parle qui tienent le
même
discours
rejoignez la première question
don merci donc si vous voulez bien
répondre merci pour observations et ces
et ces questions
euh peut-être si vous me le permettez je
je voudrais partir de la question du du
sénateur Carl monsieur le sénateur
effectivement je je crois que il me
semble que nous devrions reprendre
conscience de la nécessité de d'éduquer
par l'instruction
et je crois que c'est c'est c'est c'est
une c'est c'est une prise de conscience
qui est urgente car pour pour répondre à
votre intervention malheureusement me
semble-t-il le diagnostic n'est pas
partagé il n'est pas partagé parout et
notamment il n'est pas partagé par ceux
qui aujourd'hui encore ont la mission de
structurer la pédagogie de l'école et de
structurer notamment la formation des
enseignants je l'ai je l'ai vu j'en ai
fait l'expérience comme comme mes
collègues d'ailleurs et nous en avons
tous été marqué quel que soient
d'ailleurs nos nos origines personnel
quel que soi nos convictions
personnelles nos sensibilités politique
nous étions là comme jeunes enseignants
pour suivre notre formation et nous
étions nous avons été très très étonnés
très marqués par par ce discours et
depuis d'ailleurs que que j'ai publié ce
ce petit essai je reçois énormément de
courriers de collègues ou de collègues à
la retraite qui me qui me confient avoir
vécu de manière parfois douloureuse leur
propre expérience de cette de cette
formation les les formateurs qui que
nous rencontrions et je crois ceux qui
aujourd'hui inspire la pédagogie de de
l'école de la République sont convaincus
que l'école ne s'est pas encore assez
réformée que la transmission n'a pas
encore été assez déconstruite et que
c'est pour cette raison-là que nous
voyons encore ces inégalités dont dont
vous parliez à l'instant ces inégalités
que nous voudrions chasser prenons un
exemple tout simple l'exemple de la
polémique qui avait surgi lors du
retrait de l'épreuve de culture générale
de l'entrée des concours de des concours
d'entrée de de de sciencep Paris l'UP de
Paris comme vous le savez a retiré il y
a quelques années son épreuve de culture
générale du concours d'entrée en
adoptant ce qui est intéressant ce n'est
pas la réforme en soi mais c'est sa
justification un discours extrêmement
simple qui consiste à dire que la
culture est une occasion de
discrimination que la culture est
discriminatoire par contre séquent il
faut retirer la culture de nos épreuves
de sélection pour éviter de reproduire
ces discriminations et si nous voulons
produire de l'égalité il faut
déconstruire la culture çaen était suivi
un vaste débat et je me rappelle très
bien c'était ma première année
d'enseignement je me rappelle très bien
de ce ministère de ce communiqué qui
avait été publié par le ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et qui disait
que il fallait entreprendre une vaste
réflexion sur la place de la culture
général dans les concours de recrutement
des écoles de la fonction publique au
motif que la culture est l'occasion
d'une sélection discriminatoire cette
idée là voyez je crois elle est le
témoin du fait que le diagnostic n'est
pas partagé par tout le monde en tous
les cas le diagnostic que je viens de de
vous proposer et qui consiste à penser
au contraire que la culture est
l'occasion de toute égalité réelle de
toute liberté réelle et qu'on ne frapp
pas l'égalité à l'intérieur de notre
pays en défaisant la culture car alors
on laissera en fait les plus privilégiés
les plus favorisés c'est ce qui se
produit aujourd'hui accéder au poste de
responsabilité la culture est nécessaire
pour devenir vraiment libre pour
accomplir ses facultés pour accomplir
ses talents faire la culture c'est donc
priver ceux qui ne la reçoivent pas dans
leur famille dans leur cercle familial
dans leur milieu social c'est les privés
d'accéder à la possibilité d'accomplir
ce qu'ils sont et de constituer dans une
véritable liberté leur propre projet de
vie par voie de conséquence je le crois
profondément le diagnostic n'est pas
partager et encore faudrait-il que nous
puissions le partager avec ceux qui
aujourd'hui ont la charge de mettre en
œuvre les pédagogies de l'école car eux
pour le coup ont la conviction que c'est
parce que l'école ne s'est pas encore
assez réformée parce que la transmission
n'a pas encore été assz déconstruite que
nous sommes dans cet état d'inégalité
persistant et ceci me conduit à répondre
donc à la question que que vous posiez
je crois qu'il faudrait effectivement
rappeler peut-être dans le temps de la
formation des enseignants que c'est par
l'instruction que l'école peut éduquer
que c'est par le savoir que les
enseignants ont à transmettre qu'ils
peuvent servir une égalité et une
liberté réelle de leurs élèves et ceci
constituerait un geste
extraordinairement fort car nous avons
vécu dans notre expérience de formation
l'expérience très douloureuse d'un
soupçon porté sur notre activité d' un
soupçon porté sur notre propre savoir
voilà sans doute le plus le plus
douloureux pour un enseignant quand on
vous explique dans votre propre
formation que vous êtes le tenant d'un
système militaro hospitalo carcéral je
cite là le formateur que nous
rencontrions que l'école est à la fois
quelque chose qui tient de la caserne de
l'hôpital et de la prison quand on vous
explique que vous êtes en mettant des
notes à vos élèves le capot du système
ultralibéral et que vous préparez pour
l'avenir les masses laborieuses dans
lesquelles les multinationales iront se
servir parmi le prolétariat résigné que
vous aurez constitué pour pour elle bien
d'une certaine façon vous ressentez une
forme de culpabilité je crois qu'on ne
comprend pas la crise de l'école si on
ne comprend pas que l'éducation
nationale est comme un vaste système
entré en dépression collective nous
continuons à enseigner parce qu'il faut
bien le faire mais nous ne savons plus
pourquoi nous avons perdu le sens de la
fécondité de notre mission on nous
explique que le savoir que nous portons
est un poids infligé à nos élèves la
grande expression par exemple du bagage
culturel qu'il faudrait transmettre aux
enfants mais si la culture est un bagage
la Cult culture est un fardeau car un
bagage c'est pesant c'est pénible ça
gêne la liberté de mouvement la culture
je le crois profondément n'est pas un
bagage elle n'est pas quelque chose
d'accessoire elle n'est pas de l'ordre
de l'acquis comme on le dit souvent là
encore dans le vocabulaire pédagogique
contemporain on ne mesure pas des acquis
à l'école à l'école on apporte un
surcroit d'être et l'autorité de
l'enseignant est ce par quoi sont
augmentés les élèves de leur être propre
et de leur liberté réelle les auteurs
que nous faisons rencontrer à nos élèves
font autorité et leur autorité est
condition de toute liberté nous l'avons
vu évidemment dans cette période
troublée qui qui a suivi l'histoire de
de le drame la tragédie de Charlie Hebdo
nous l'avons vu l'autorité des
enseignants qui a disparu n'a pas
disparu au profit d'une liberté des
élèves lorsque l'autorité de l'école
s'effondre et bien nos élèves sont
abandonnés à l'oppression de ces
discours de ces discours simplistes et
superficiels de cette coerition nouvelle
que l'on voit fleurir sur internet de
ces idéologies qui les prennent en otage
l'autorité de l'école est la condition
de toute liberté elle a été d'ailleurs
pour nous-même aussi la condition de
notre propre liberté d'aujourd'hui et
nous devrions en être reconnaissant de
cela de ce point de vue je crois que
vous voyez affirmer que le savoir et la
condition de toute liberté ce serait
faire un geste extraordinairement fort à
l'égard du monde enseignant ce serait
dire aux enseignants que le savoir
qu'ils ont reçu que la formation qu'ils
ont suivi est féconde pour les élèves
qu'ils rencontrent et que ce savoir
qu'ils ont désiré partager et ce dans
quoi se constituera toute liberté et
toute humanité pour le monde qui vient
pour les générations qui naissent
aujourd'hui et les enseignants d'une TER
façon je crois ont soif de ce discours
et si je peux me permettre de me faire
ici humblement le porte parole de mes
collègues nous avons soif d'un discours
qui redonne sens à notre métier et nous
avons besoin que le politique se
ressaisisse de ce
discours le politique aujourd'hui est
dans une situation très pénible à
l'égard du monde enseignant encore une
fois quand nous entendons notre ministre
par exemple parler elle-même de
l'évaluation sans note qui serait la
seule évaluation bienveillante nous
entendons notre ministre implicitement
dire que notre notre activité qui
consiste à mettre des notes est une
activité malveillante implicitement
quand le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et vous voyez que ce n'est pas
une question de partie car la période
dont je parle était celle d'une
précédente majorité quand le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale et de
l'enseignement supérieur publie un
communiqué disant que la culture est
l'occasion d'une sélection
discriminatoire en fait il accuse les
enseignants de reproduire des inégalités
et donc nous nous sentons coupables et
on ne peut pas penser le malaise du
monde enseignant sans cette espèce de
culpabilité qui est je crois infondée
mais qui est entretenue par le disc
cours commun et notamment c'est vrai
malheureusement par le discours des
politiques à l'égard de l'école toute
tendance confondue ici mon propos n'est
pas de de de politique secteur ou
partisan je crois que c'est là encore
l'objet d'une prise de conscience qui
doit être
collective alors comment faire
maintenant pour que tous puissent
accéder à cette culture commune et vous
le rappeliez monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez je crois beaucoup travaillé sur
cette question du du socle commun des
connaissance vous rappeliez les les
résistances qui qui parfois naissent
dans l'espace de de de de nos classes
les résistances qui qui parfois naissent
à certains enseignements à une certaine
transmission ces résistances que nous
nous rencontrons dont nous faisons
parfois l'expérience je crois que ces
résistances nous avons malgré tout
tendance à les exagérer nous
avons nous avons placé l'enfant au
centre du système scolaire et c'était
tout à fait naturel l'enfant a toujours
été au centre du système scolaire parce
que évidemment le but de l'école n'est
pas le savoir en tant que tel n'est pas
l'éudition mais mais bien la croissance
de l'enfant qui lui est confié le vrai
problème n'est pas que nous ayons placé
l'enfant au centre du système scolaire
le vrai problème est que nous ayons
construit une école qui soit toujours et
systématiquement à la hauteur de
l'enfant à hauteur d'enfant à la hauteur
de ce que nous pensons être ses
capacités à l'instant donné à hauteur de
ce ce dont nous croyons que cela
constituera pour lui un plaisir une
satisfaction un intérêt immédiat nous
avons fait de notre école le règne de
l'immédiateté le règne d'une
satisfaction d'un intérêt immédiat et
nous avons voulu bannir tout ce qui
semblait constituer une médiation
l'expérience d'une rencontre avec
quelque chose qui serait un
intermédiaire en vue d'un progrès en vue
d'un changement nous avons voulu bannir
d'une certaine façon tout ce qui
représentait cette médiation le cours
magistral la lecture continue l'effort
qui consiste à apprendre par cœur le
travail de la mémoire tout cela nous
l'avons banni et nous avons cru nous
concilier ainsi l'affection de nos
élèves nous avons pensé que faire une
école qui ne serait pas trop difficile
pour eux ce serait faire une école qui
serait plus sympathique plus plaisante
une école dans laquelle ils auraient
plus de plaisir à aller mais en fait en
réalité c'est une catastrophe parce que
ce que les élèves attendent c'est
précisément quelque chose qui les
dépasse quelque chose qui les élève mon
expérience personnelle
d'enseignant c'est que lorsque nous
suivons les consignes qui nous étaient
données celles qui consistent par
exemple à ne jamais faire de cours
magistral à organiser en permanence des
débats des discussions des ateliers
participatifs lorsque nous passons notre
temps à soliciter les élèves en leur
demandant de produire par eux-mêmes leur
propres savoir alors nous construisons
une école d'un ennui mortelle car si on
vous demande tout le temps votre avis
c'est vraiment pas la peine d'aller à
l'école votre avis vous l'avez déjà si
vous venez par exemple en cours de
philosophie pour qu'on vous demande ce
que vous pensez sur le bonheur c'est
vraiment pas la peine d'aller en cours
de philosophie vous avez déjà une idée
sur la question vous venez en cours de
philosophie pour rencontrer une histoire
qui vous précède pour rencontrer des
auteurs qui justement fassent autorité
vous venez en cours d'abord pour écouter
et non pas d'abord pour parler d'abord
pour recevoir et non pas d'abord pour
participer la participation la création
la créativité viennent ensuite et
viennent après et c'est le propre de
toute notre expérience humaine que nous
ne sommes pas immédiatement capables de
notre propre créativité ce dont un
enfant est capable il ne le possède pas
encore ce dont un enfant sera vraiment
capable demain et ce dont il sera par
nature capable il a besoin d'abord de
beaucoup recevoir pour pouvoir
l'accomplir et c'est le pari de toute
éducation que que de regarder un enfant
non pas comme ce qu'il est maintenant à
un instant T mais de le regarder comme
étant capable de chos qu'il ne maîtrise
pas encore et mon expérience personnelle
c'est que lorsque vous venez en cours au
contraire en affirmant que vous avez
quelque chose à transmettre quelque
chose qui mérite d'être entendu quelque
chose qui mérite qu'on fasse silence
pour un temps alors vous rencontrez
c'est vrai des résistances car
l'éducation est toujours une tâche
difficile et de fait elle se fait
toujours d'une certaine façon dans la
douleur vous rencontrez c vrai des
résistances et vous avez une tâche
difficile devant vous mais en même temps
commence en même temps qu'une forme de
guerre une magnifique histoire d'amour
lorsque vous rentrez en classe en disant
à vos élèves que vous avez quelque chose
à leur transmettre alors de fait il
deviennent réceptifs ils deviennent
attentifs avec le temps peut-être c'est
vrai mais ils le deviennent vraiment et
même et peut-être surtout dans les
endroits qu'il est convenu d'appeler
défavorisé dans les zones les plus
difficiles dans les zones les plus
sensibles j'ai rencontré cette soif
immense cette intérêt pour ce qu'il y a
de plus grand et de plus beau dans la
culture cette soif d'intelligence cette
soif de réflexion cette soif de la
littérature cette soif de la poésie je
vais les rencontrer peut-être surtout
dans ces lieux où nous avons devant nous
des élèves qui ont conscience de manquer
de tout tout et qui ont conscience par
ce manque d'avoir soif du meilleur donc
je crois voyez au fond finalement les
résistances ne sont pas si grandes que
nous nous l'imaginons souvent et j'ai
partagé ces expériences avec beaucoup de
collègues y compris avec des collègues
d'histoire on parle souvent de
l'histoire comme d'une discipline
difficile à enseigner je crois que
lorsqu'un enseignant arrive avec une
authentique passion de l'histoire
conscient que l'histoire de notre pays
est belle qu'elle mérite d'être reçue et
que tous ceux qui sont dans l'espace de
la classe étant français ou étant
habitant en France en sont légitimement
les héritiers lorsqu'on arrive avec ce
sentiment que tout enfant a droit de
connaître l'histoire de ce pays dans
lequel il grandit alors dans ce cas on
rencontre une attention on la suscite on
la fait naître et les élèves répondent
comme on écho à notre désir de
transmettre par leur propre désir
d'apprendre évidemment encore une fois
ça se fait toujours dans la difficulté
on peut pas imaginer que l'école soit
autre chose que l'expérience de la
difficulté pédagogique Alain écrivait
que la pédagogie c'est la science des
professeurs chahutés et de fait je ne
voudrais pas faire ici celui qui par une
espèce de prestige usurpé vous ferit
croire qu'il n'a jamais été chahuté bien
sûr bien sûr la pédagogie et la science
des professeurs chahuté mais en même
temps à l'intérieur même de cet effort
et de cette difficulté que nous
rencontrons parfois à l'intérieur même
de ces résistances que nous voyons se
lever devant nous il y a toujours comme
un appel et l'appel de ces élèves qui
attendent d'être élevés qui attendent
d'être des élèves Gustave tibon disait
ce qui m'a toujours beaucoup guidé dans
ma Tâage d'éducateur celui qui ne me
donne rien c'est celui qui ne me donne
pas l'occasion de me donner celui qui
d'une certaine façon ne me donne pas
l'occasion de me dépasser nous avons
construit une école d'une incroyable
pauvreté précisément parce qu'elle ne
donne jamais aux élèves ou si peu si
rarement l'occasion de se dépasser
l'occasion d'aller au-delà de leur
propre capacité voyez il y a une forme
de contradiction absolue de ce point de
vue-là on parle de l'éducation comme
d'une violence c'est ce que disait
Pierre Bourdieu tout acte éducatif est
violence on parle de la transmission
comme d'une forme de coerition on parle
de la notation comme d'une brutalité
mais nos élèves ils attendent au
contraire l'occasion de recevoir quelque
chose qui les dépasse ils attendent une
occasion de se dépasser et dès que
l'école est finie ils vont par exemple
faire du sport et quand ils vont faire
du sport il rentrent pas sur le terrain
de foot en disant on va pas compter les
points parce que ce sera trop violent
pour celui qui va perdre non ils ont
envie d'être stimulés ils ont envie
d'être dépassés ils ont envie de donner
le meilleur d'eux- même c'est à ça
qu'ils aspirent et d'une certaine façon
je crois voyez pour aller jusqu'au bout
encore du raisonnement je crois que de
façon monstrueuse et de façon atroce
c'est précisément ce que l'État
islamique propose à nos élèves c'est ce
que l'idéologie la plus atroce propose à
nos élèves une occasion de se donner une
occasion de se dépasser une occasion de
se sacrifier c'est peut-être abominable
de dire ça mais malgré tout je crois que
c'est vrai nous avons dit à nos élèves
on ne va jamais vous déranger on ne va
jamais vous imposer quelque chose de
trop difficile vous inquiétez pas on
vous respecte on vous laisse dans votre
cocon on vous laisse dans votre bulle on
vous laisse être immédiatement ce que
vous êtes on ne vous demandera jamais de
faire eff forort sur vous-même et nous
avons cru par là nous concilier leur
amitié mais en fait en réalité ce qu'il
cherchent dans dans ce monde nos élèves
ça n'est pas simplement une raison de
vivre c'est une raison de donner leur
vie ça n'est pas simplement une raison
de de de de de de de se trouver
correctement en ce monde de consommer de
vivre une existence qui serait à la
mesure de leur propre désir mais c'est
une occasion de se donner une occasion
de se dépasser une occasion d'être élevé
et l'expérience que j'ai faite encore
une fois et c'est ma grande source
d'espérance vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que j'étais optimiste je sais pas si je
suis optimiste parce je pense que nous
n'avons pas beaucoup de raison d'être
optimiste mais en revanche j'ai une très
grande espérance ce qui est tout à fait
différent je crois qu'il faut regarder
la réalité telle qu'elle est avec toutes
les difficultés qu'elle comporte et
aller au-delà de de cette de cette
difficulté c'est précisément ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'espérance et ce qui
fond de mon espérance c'est cette
expérience que j'ai faite si souvent de
la soif des élèves et notamment de la
soif des élèves dans ces milieux les
plus défavorisés dans ces milieux les
plus fragilisés dans ces lieux c'est
vrai aussi où nous avions devant nous
des élèves issus de culture extrêmement
varié issus d'origine extrêmement
diverse dans ces lieux-là j'ai rencontré
peut-être la plus grande soif de notre
propre culture et de ce qu'elle comporte
de meilleur et c'est cela qui fonde mon
espérance merci beaucoup pour cette
intervention brillante et optimiste
pessimiste ça ça dépend comment chacun
le ressent en tout cas enthousiaste et
j'espère que vous ne perdrez pas tout
cet enthousiaste au fur à mesure de de
vos rencontres et de votre enseignement
dans différents écoles parce que
bravo
merci tropôt à l'université quoi merci
beaucoup merci en tous les cas de de vos
travau et je fais confiance à votre
commission comme comme jeune enseignant
et comme et comme jeune citoyen aussi et
je vous remercie beaucoup de vous
pencher sur ces sur ces questions je
crois que peut-être les les périodes
difficiles que nous vivons sont sont
justement l'occasion d'une prise de
conscience qui qui sera salutaire aussi
bien d'ailleurs dans dans l'opinion
publique que que dans nos élus merci
infiniment en tous les cas de de m'avoir
reçu et j'espère que que de vos travaux
pourront pourront sortir ce discours
dont nous avons tant besoin et dont je
vous suis déjà par par par avance
infiniment
reconnaissant tout sera problème de
posologie n'est-ce pas chers collègues
ben je crois que vous avez une bonne
image diagnostique remède et posologie
merci mes chers collègues nous recevons
maintenant Madame Gabrielle de Rameau
professeur de lettres et auteur d'un
ouvrage au titre d'écapant sur votre
expérience d'enseignante collège inique
Tam mère titulaire d'une licence de
philosophie et d'une maîtrise de lettres
modern vous avez été admise au concours
du capess de lettre modern en
1998 vous êtes depuis cette date
professeur de français dans les collèges
et lycées de région parisienne dans
votre livitre vous racontez le quotidien
d'une jeune enseignante en établissement
difficile dans l'Académie de créteille
tout d'abord puis à Paris vous y
regrettez notamment l'absence de soutien
de la part de l'institution et le manque
de formation des enseignants la
commission d'enquête a souhaité vous
entendre afin que vous puissiez nous
faire part de ces réalités que vous
vivez sur le terrain bien sûr nous
allons aussi sur le terrain les
événements de janvier 2015
s'inscrivent-ils selon vous dans une
tendance de fond traduisant une perte de
repère si c'est le cas quelles sont les
causes de cette dérive et quelle mesure
pourrait être pris pour l'enrayer comme
le bureau de la commission d'enquête l'a
décidé cette audition sera captée et
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat et elle fera également l'objet
d'un compte-rendu publié dans le recueil
des travaux de commission accessible en
version papier sur le site internet du
Sénat avant de vous passer la parole
madame le formalisme des commissions
d'enquête me conduit à vous demander de
prêter serment je suis également tenu de
vous indiquer que tout faux témoignage
devant notre commission serait passible
des peines prévues aux articles 43413 et
43415 du code pénal en conséquence je
vous vous invite à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levez la main droite et dites je le jure
je le jure je vous remercie selon
l'usage habituel je vous propose de nous
faire part de vos observations durant
une dizaine de minutes après quoi notre
rapporteur Jacques groperin et les
membres de la commission qui le souhait
pourront vous poser leurs questions vous
avez la parole madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs en septembre 2001 nous avons
dû faire respecter dans nos classes 3
minutes de silence pour les victimes du
World Trade Center mes élèves ont
entonné alors des champs Palestiniens
jeunes professeurs interdit devant leur
réaction je les ai laissé chanter
personne à l'époque n'a parlé de ces
incidents et pourtant ils furent aussi
nombreux nous personnels de l'Éducation
nationale avions pressenti que rien ne
serait plus pareil déjà agité par les
soubressau du conflit
israélo-palestinien l'école subirait les
répliques des violents conflits à venir
aujourd'hui on nous parle de réaffirmer
les grands principes de la République à
nos élèves la laïcité en particulier
mais c'est un combat que nous menons
déjà tous les jours nous sommes en
première ligne pour expliquer et
réexpliquer inlassablement la place de
l'école et celle de la religion la
séparation du temporel et du spirituel
l'étanchéité nécessaire entre la sphère
publique et la sphère privée la loi de
1905 qui nous semble si naturel ne l'est
pas pour bon nombre de nos élèves dont
certains viennent de pays où la religion
est partout près car religion d'État
nous devons en premier lieu expliquer
que si nous respectons en tant que
citoyens les lois de la République c'est
parce que nous les avons choisis et voté
parce qu'ell nous protège et non parce
qu'ell nous contraignent ou que nous
craignons de quelconque représail
respecter la loi parce que nous l'avons
validé et non parce que nous la
subissons pour faire comprendre aux
élèves d'aujourd'hui l'esprit de la loi
de 1905 nous avons à rappeler les grands
massacres dus aux guerres de religion
qui opposèrent dans l'histoire
protestant et catholique en France le
plus jamais ça garanti par une invention
unique dans l'histoire de l'humanité la
laïcité qui au contraire d'interdire
toute religion comme le pensent beaucoup
de nos élèves permet à chacun d'être
respecté dans ses croyances dans sa foi
comme dans son athéisme quel que soit
son origine ou sa couleur de peau la
laïcité crée un espace protégé et commun
propice notamment à la sérénité
nécessaire à l'étude et à l'instruction
c'est peu de dire qu'elle nous est plus
que jamais indispensable à à l'école en
2015 les professeurs de l'école publique
enseignent depuis longtemps le fait
religieux les programmes de français
d'histoire suivent la même protection
progression pardon en 6e l'Antiquité en
5e le moyen-âge en 4e les 17 18e et 19e
siècle et en 3e les 20e et 21e sièclle
lorsqu'en 6e le programme nous demande
d'étudier la Bible nous adaptons
évidemment cet enseignement à notre
public scolaire et proposons une lecture
comparée avec le Coran privilégiant les
points de rencontre des grandes
traditions monothéiste comme par exemple
la la figure emblématique du patriarche
Abraham Ibrahim oou l'étude comparée du
jardin d'Eden dans la tradition
hébraïque ou coranique de même en 5e la
chanson de rouand où les épopées des
croisades sont l'occasion de mettre en
lumière les échanges entre la
civilisation occidentale et le monde
arabo-musulman mettre l'accent sur les
rencontres fructueuses pour la médecine
l'architecture les sciences les arts et
les lettres plutôt que les sur les
confrontations guerrières poser la
religion comme objet des étude
s'instruire discuter débattre en
apprenant à mettre de côté son histoire
personnelle ses croyances ses traditions
qui tout aussi forte et respectable
qu'ell soit n'ont pas leur place dans
l'enceinte protégée de l'école laïque il
nous faut lutter sans cesse contre les
tentative de confiscation du discours
sur la religion et nous montrer
particulièrement ferme sur le principe
que la religion est un objet d'étude au
même titre que la biologie ou la
peinture dans une époque très empreinte
de spiritualité où nos élèves parlent
volontiers de religion parce qu'elle
fait partie de leur pratique quotidienne
et familiale il est primordial de
rappeler que l'école a le droit de
parler de la religion de la comparer de
la critiquer tout en garantissant à
chacun le respect absolu de ses
convictions personnelles l'autre écueil
auquel est confronté l'école
d'aujourd'hui est la pensée complotiste
qui rend suspecte toute parole présentée
comme officielle on nous menent tout est
faux tout est falsifié il faut se méfier
des journalistes des politiques des
professeurs instruction dispensée à
l'école vu comme propagande prisme
pervers qui rend suspecte et donc
contestable la parole du professeur
c'est au nom de ce grand complot
imaginaire que fut contestée la véracité
des attentats de 2015 une sordide mise
en scène orchestrée par les services
secret français pour salir l'islam
soi-disant tout peut alors être remis en
question les sujets épineux comme le
génocide arménien la Seconde Guerre
mondiale la Choa la décolonisation le le
calvare d'Ilan Alimi la culpabilité de
Mera comme les bases mêmees de notre
pensée occidentale la théorie de
l'évolution ou la révolution
copernicienne ce qui rend nos élèves
perméable à ces divagations toxiques est
avant
tout l'appauvrissement dramatique de
leur vocabulaire et donc de leur
facultés à exprimer et à penser le monde
imaginez que pour beaucoup de nos élèves
des mots d'usage courant comme pâle ou
pénombre ne sont pas compréhensible même
dans les bons établissements une grande
partie des élèves ne comprend que
superficiellement les textes L ou
étudier ils donnent le change car ils
comprennent globalement mais ils n'ont
pas accès à une compréhension fine d'une
réalité de plus en plus complexe ils
sont les proies faciles pour n'importe
quel manipulateur qui serura leur
montrer une vision du monde simpliste
qui leur permettra donc plus lisible et
plus crédible l'école est le dernier
creusé où se rencontent les citoyens de
demain le seul endroit où s'écrit le
roman national or nous avons de moins en
moins de temps et de moyens pour les
aider à écrire ensemble une histoire
faite de paix et d'enrichissement
réciproque
jamais l'inégalité entre nos élèves n'a
été si criante entre de bons élèves
toujours plus stimulés et cultivés et
des élèves laissés au bord du chemin
sans bagage sans espoir cible tout
désigné des bonimenteurs de tout poil
nous sommes particulièrement inquiet du
projet de réforme qui s'annonce qui
prévoit entre autres l'apprentissage
d'une deuxième langue vivante dès la 5e
comment imaginer que ce dispositif ne
creuse pas encore plus les différen déjà
insupportable entre des élèves
culturellement favorisés qui absorberont
sans peine ce sur cro de travail et nos
élèves moins privilégiés pour qui cette
deuxième langue vivante se en sera en
réalité une troisième parlant à leur
dans leur maison leur langue maternelle
et ayant déjà apprendre le français
ainsi qu'une autre langue à l'entrée en
6e l'autre victime collatérale de ce
projet sera l'enseignement du latin et
du grec que plus aucun élève ne choisira
désormais et qui offre pourtant
l'occasion unique de jeter des ponts
entre le Nord et le Sud de part et
d'autres de la m de la Méditerranée
notre berceau de civilisation ce vaste
empire dont nos ancêtres étaient tous
citoyens et dont nous sommes aujourd'hui
les héritiers cette réforme va à
l'encontre des besoins urgents constatés
sur le terrain nos élèves ont besoin de
se sentir inscrit dans une histoire
commune et de plus d'heures consacré au
savoirs fondamentaux savoir lire savoir
écrire savoir compter pour comprendre le
monde complexe qui est le nôtre et pour
en devenir des citoyens armés pour les
grands défis qui s'annoncent
ensemble merci beaucoup madame pour ce
propos liminire qui est très clair donc
le rapporteur va vous poser quelques
questions merci pour le tableau aussi
euh réaliste en tout cas que vous vivez
vous qu'on entend pas toujours de la
part d'autres d'autres acteurs de de ce
qu'on appelle la communauté éducative à
savoir les recteurs les inspecteurs euh
et parfois quelques ministres qui sont
peut-être un peu plus éloigné en tout
cas du du champ et de la pratique que
vous-même euh donc vraiment merci de
pour votre témoignage j'aurai plusieurs
questions la première question euh
lorsque vous parlez de collège inique
est-ce que bon on a bien compris que
c'est un jeu de mot aussi mais est-ce
que c'est aussi peut-être une remise en
question du collège unique parce qu'on
en a pas parlé on en a parlé quelquefois
il y a eu il y a parfois des euh des
interprétations différentes et puis
surtout euh des prises de vue
différentes dans la mesure ou pour
certains il faut garder un collège
unique pour d'autres euh et c'est vrai
que lorsqu'on parle du redoublement on
veut éviter redoublement on veut éviter
les notes mais dans d'autres pays le
redoublement n'existe peut-être pas mais
il y a aussi des voies d'orientation qui
sont préalables et qui permett justement
de l'éviter euh plus plusieurs questions
la deuxième question c'est euh euh bon
vous décrivez bien sûr dans votre dans
votre livre la vie d'une enseignante au
sein d'un établissement difficile
comment ça se manifeste vous vous avez
répondu en partie mais si vous voulez
peut-être euh compléter comment ça se
manifeste véritablement cette perte de
de repère républicain de de vos élèves
vous parlez également vous dénoncez
l'absence de de soutien hiérarchique
voir la culpabilisation des enseignants
face à certains comportement des élèves
est-ce que vous avez constaté une
évolution depuis le début de de votre
carrière vis-à-vis de cela ou un manque
de soutien de la part de de la
hiérarchie bon les mesures annoncées par
le Président de la République vous et la
la ministre d'éducation vous avez les
avez esquissé en tout cas donc je ne REP
poserai pas la question mais peut-être
enfin dernière question pour laisser
aussi la parole à mes à mes collègues
quelles seraient les mesures qui
pourraient être prises pour lutter
contre contre cette perte de repère de
valeur mais contre tout
cela bien
alors alors en ce qui concerne le
collège unique je ne suis pas partisane
de de remettre en question cette
organisation scolaire qui me semble
effectivement profitable à tous d'être
ensemble au moins jusqu'au lycée euh et
justement de d'être confronté à d'autres
milieux d'autres d'autres élèves que
soi-même cependant vous l'avez souligné
nous avons aussi de graves manquements à
l'organisation de l'enseignement
professionnel qui est encore vu comme
une voie de garage alors que il se
trouve que nous avons des des
établissements professionnels de haute
qualité qui promettent un avenir
beaucoup plus brillant à nos élèves que
ceux qui choisissent d'aller à
l'université et dont on s dont la
plupart sortent sans aucun diplôme je
crois que les choses commencent à
avancer mais vraiment à petit pas et il
faut vraiment travailler dans ce sens
donner envie aux élèves d'acquérir un
métier un savoir-faire une liberté une
une place dans la société qu'ils ne
trouveront pas sinon euh alors un
collège unique oui mais il faut quand
même garder à l'esprit que nous avons 32
élèves par classe et que à ce stade
c'est il est très difficile pour nous
enseignants d'avoir un suivi
personnalisé comme on nous demande de
plus en plus c'est vraiment des des
situations d'enseignement qui sont
difficiles et qui n'avantagent pas
évidemment c'est toujours les mauvais
élèves qui en font le prix car les bons
non'ont finalement assez peu besoin du
professeur en ce qui concerne la perte
de
repèr je crois que les deux piliers
fondamentaux que nous essayons de
transmettre à puisqueon parle de valeur
républicaine oui mais lesquelles la
laïcité dont j'ai bien parlé je crois et
qui me tient beaucoup à cœur ainsi qu'à
tous mes collègues et il y a un autre
aspect qui est là beaucoup plus
difficile à transmettre c'est la
méritocratie donc jusqu'à ma génération
nous avons tous profiter entrer à
l'école et avoir l'espoir d'en sortir
grandi quel que soit notre origine quel
que soit notre couleur de peau
aujourd'hui ça n'est plus possible cet
ascenseur social est en panne on le lit
partout et on le répète mais c'est la
vérité aujourd'hui l'école n'est pas
l'endroit où vous allez faire carrière
et les élèves le savent parfaitement
sans entrer dans des détails sordides il
faut bien s'imaginer que dans certains
quartiers de notre République le seul
choix qu'on laisse à nos élèves c'est
soit une radicalisation religieuse pour
espérer acquérir un statut soit le
trafic de drogue et ça tant qu'on l'a
pas imaginé et vécu on ne peut pas nous
dire à nous professeurs que notre
travail est mal fait voilà car il faut
quand même s imaginez que ces gens
doivent gagner leur vie un jour ou
l'autre et que quand on est abandonné de
tous et ben parfois on n pas le choix de
choisir quelque chose une voix plus
noble et cette méritocratie est mise en
panne aussi à l'école puisque les élèves
voient très bien que quel que soit leur
résultat de toute façon ils passeront en
classe supérieure certains élèves posent
tellement de problèmes qu'il n'est pas
question de les garder une année de plus
au collège personne n'a envie de les
garder et eux-même n'ont pas envie de
rester euh nous avons dans toutes nos
classes même dans les établissements 10
de centrre-ville des élèves fantômes qui
assistent à 8h de cours par jour dont
ils ne comprennent pas un traîre mot les
deux premières années ils sont gentils
et calmes et les deux dernières années
ils sont très agités et plus du tout
calme mais il faut se mettre à leur
place aussi et qu'est-ce qu'on offre à
ces élèves comme perspective mais pas
grand-chose voilà pas grand-chose il y a
150000 élèves qui sortent à 16 ans sans
aucune qualification estce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que la plupart
d'entre eux sortent moins avvant du
collège qu'il n'y sont entrés car ces
années d'abétissement d'abrutissement
évidemment font des des dommages
terribles chez ces jeunes alors à propos
du soutien
hiérarchique ça cela vée vraiment des
établissements moi j'ai la chance entre
guillemets d'en faire beaucoup car je
n'ai pas de poste fixe je suis cette
année sur trois établissements par
exemple ce qui me permet évidemment de
comparer les directions les unes avec
les autres euh la chose dont nous
manquons le plus puisque nous parlions
de ces classes à plus de 30 élèves ce
sont des surveillants parce que des
classes de 30 élèves vous pouvez imposer
votre loi à l'intérieur de votre classe
avec de l'expérience et de l'autorité
vous y arrivez en revanche il est
complètement illusoire de s'imaginer que
cette autorité va s'étendre dans les
couloirs ou dans la cour de récréation
ou dans les toilettes où il n'y a
pratiquement aucun adulte pour
surveiller ces jeunes et il se passe des
choses même dans tes des établissements
qui ont l'air comme ça à priori
tranquille terrible qu'on soupçonne
qu'on connaît mais nous n'avons aucun
moyen d'y mettre de l'ordre voilà ça
c'est la première chose des choses à
développer des choses du trafic de
drogue des filles qui se prostituent
dans les toilettes des bagarres
incessantes des gestes qui ont l'air
anodin pour les élèves mais qui mettent
une ambiance terrible par exemple le jeu
qui consiste à se mettre une grande
claque quand on passe dans un couloir et
qu'on voit des élèves rangés voilà des
gestes de violence quotidiennes physique
et verbal hein puisque les élèves ne se
s'adressent pas la parole il s'aboi les
uns sur les autres euh et si on peut
faire respecter une certaine politesse
dans ses classes les couloirs sont de
véritables zones de non droit dans
certains
établissements pour les mesures qu'on
pourrait prendre pour transmettre les
valeurs républicaines je n'ai
malheureusement pas de remède à proposer
je ne peux faire que le constat que nous
avons besoin d'aide il y a du Feu à tous
les étages de la maternelle à
l'université tout le monde le constate
mais maintenant nous attendons des
résultats concrets non pas tant en terme
de moyens comme on attend on entend
souvent mais en terme de direction nous
voudrions une direction qui soit claire
qui ne soit pas changeante car nous
professeurs nous nous inscrivons dans la
durée dans le temps pour transmettre ce
que nous avons à donner à nos élèves
nous voudrions que l'école ce d'être le
laboratoire fou d'expérience pédagogique
qui viennent tous les 3 4 ans
bouleverser tout ce que nous avons mis
en place qui nous coûte beaucoup de
temps en terme de réunion de de papier à
écrire qui remonte ou qui ne remonte pas
nous en savons rien et en attendant nos
élèves ont besoin de nous nous sommes
plus utiles dans nos classes face à nos
élèves que dans une salle de réunion à
discuter pour savoir s'il va falloir
parler de notes de couleurs de
compétences et je ne sais quoi d'autre
tout ce jargon qui nous arrive et dont
on ne sait que faire et qui ne répond
absolument pas à nos besoins et à ceux
de nos
élèves merci beaucoup Monsieur Le Gendre
première question monsieur Carl après
oui monsieur le Jun oui madame la
Présidente j'ai bien entendu ce que
madame a dit à propos de l'apprentissage
de la deuxèe langue bon et enseigné le
français jadis j'attache évidment
beaucoup d' à ce que la notre langue
soit prioritairement bien comprise et
bien maîtrisée mais est-ce que dans
certains collèges dont les enfants ne
sont pas de langue maternelle française
il ne serait pas utile de s'interroger
sur la possibilité de d'apprendre ou
d'enseigner dans leur langue d'origine
c'est ce type d'exp a été fait par
exemple en Suède et il a parfois donné
des résultats il s'agit pas de ne pas
apprendre la langue nationale la langue
la langue du pays dans lequelle on se
trouve il faut au contraire l'prendre
mais si nous avons des élèves qui chez
eux parle et parle parfois mal la langue
d'origine de leurs parents si et qui ne
maîtrise pas la langue française on peut
se demander comment ils peuvent
communiquer dans de bonnes conditions
avec l'extérieur et donc est-ce qu'il
faut nécessairement retarder pour eux la
l'apprentissage de non pas de n'importe
quelle seconde langue mais de la langue
de leur pays d'origine je pense en
particulier à ce grand problème et très
délicat de l'apprentissage de l'arabe en
en France je voulais vous poser cette
question je ne sais pas s'il y a eu des
expériences où l'arabe a pu être
enseigné comme langue première à après
le français dans des établissements
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous en
pensez monsieur
Carl oui merci madame la présidente
madame merci de nous avoir rappelé la
réalité qui est la vôtre et qui est
celle de bon nombre de vos collègues à
qui nous devons respect et gratitude
devant la tâche qui est ou la mission
qui est la vôtre vous avez dit qu'il
fallait plus d'heures consacrées aux
fondamentaux je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais est-ce que il y a
uniquement le problème j'allais dire de
temps consacré qui est indispensable
c'est clair est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi
un problème de pédagogie d'enseignement
car sorti de la pédagogie de la doxa de
la rue de Grenel il y a pas de salut or
chacun sait l'Ance de l'effit maître qui
a eu un certain nombre de
d'expérimentations qui on qui ont été
faites notamment par Monsieur zormand he
qui montre combien en fonction de la
pédagogie qui est dispensée les
résultats peuvent euh
s'améliorer merci si vous voulez bien
répondre alors en ce qui concerne
l'apprentissage de la langue d'origine
comme langue vivante
première oui des expériences ont été
menées tout à fait alors premier écueil
évidemment c'est le recrutement des
professeurs d'Arabes qui a toujours posé
problème vous le savez le deuxième
écueil que je vois c'est le risque de
repli communautaire
avec au contraire de ce qu'on cherche
une Concorde et une unité au contraire
des
cours qui seraient en option et qui du
coup partageraient les élèves et la
troisième écueil auquel nous sommes
confrontés et c'est effectivement un
sujet de préoccupation pour beaucoup de
professeurs c'est que bon nombre de nos
élèves de confessions musulmanes dont
l'arabe n'est pas la langue d'origine
prennent le soir ce qu'ils appellent des
cours d'Arabes alors la plupart d'entre
eux ce sont de véritables cours d'Arama
nous les voyons réciter leurs leçons en
oppose mais certains vont dans des
écoles qui sont en fait des écoles
coraniques et nous avons un gros
problème avec ces élèves qui vous
expliquent qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire
leur travail demander à l'école parce
que ils ont trop de travail dans ces
écoles où finalement on se rend compte
que l'enseignement dispensé est au mieux
une longue litanie de récitation au pire
des conseils
pour mais jus qui irait jusqu'à comment
se met la zis an à l'école alors là nous
avons un gros problème ce qu'on appelle
les cours du soir subventionnés souvent
par l'état français et part des
associations qui mériteraient qu'on
aille jeter un coup d'œil sur ce qu'ell
propose à nos élèves et dans quelle
mesure ell ne font pas contre-poids au
discours que nous tenons à nos élèves
euh l'autre
chose concernant bon le je ne suis pas
professeur de langue alors il me sera
difficile d'aller plus loin sur ce
propos euh à propos des heures
consacrées aux fondamentaux et de la
remise en question de la pédagogie je
crois que la pédagogie aujourd'hui c'est
la le grand avantage du métier de
professeur c'est que nous sommes assez
libres dans nos classes d'exercer la
pédagogie que nous avons choisi avec
notre inspecteur et évidemment en
concorde avec nos autres collègues de
langue de et moi pour moi de lettres je
crois que le
nombre le choix pédagogique n'est pas si
important que le nombre d'heures que
nous avons à y consacrer alors il y a
quelques années c'est mise en place ce
qu'on appelons les IDD ce soit des
parcours croisés entre plusieurs
disciplines qui reviennent aussi à la
mode et nous avons nous professeurs de
lettres donné nos heures d'enseignement
de français consacré à ces projets 3 ans
plus tard ce grand projet est abandonné
mais nous professeurs de français
n'avons pas retrouvé notre horaire de
français et donc il y a beaucoup
d'heures qui sont euh qui ont ainsi
disparu de notre grille horaire et ça
c'est un vrai problème
là on parle de de nous enlever nos
heures de soutien qui sont pourtant
essentielles et auquels nous consacrons
vraiment mais tellement
d'énergie voilà nous sommes vraiment
très inquiets sur les répartitions et
notamment en en français et en
mathématique merci Madame
trundler merci madame la Présidente vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de de
l'enseignant qui se trouve devant sa
classe et qui peut même moyenne en 30
élèves et je peux le concevoir
obtenir un respect de l'autorité de
l'attention mais que cela n'est plus le
cas sorti de de la classe de la salle de
classe vous demandiez enfin vous
proposiez qu'il y ait plus de
d'encadrant des surveillants et cetera
est-ce que vous pensez c'est une
question est-ce que vous
pensez qu'en augmentant la présence des
enseignants dans les établissements on
peut
infléchir ce mouvement de violence ce
mouvement que que vous avez décrit avec
MTE Moutte explication et et d'exemples
est-ce que l'enseignant peut jouer un
rôle dans cette dans cette dérive en
dehors de la salle de
classe oui tout à fait alors je ne nous
imaginons pas que le professeur arrive
au lycée 5 minutes avant son heure de
cours et repart dès que la dernière nous
passons on beaucoup de temps dans les
établissements et je pense beaucoup plus
de temps que nos aînés euh évidemment le
rôle du professeur ne s'arrête pas à la
porte de sa classe et nous sommes
évidemment tout à fait conscients et
attentifs à ce qui se passe dans les
couloirs mais euh reprendre un élève qui
n'est pas un de vos élèves qui n'est
fait pas partie de votre classe vous
expose à beaucoup d'insolence voire de
violence parce que l'élève ne comprend
pas pourquoi en dehors de de sa classe
ou de la vôtre vous faites comme il
disent la police de quoi vous de quoi
vous mêlez-vous madame euh pourquoi me
reprenez-vous j'ai le droit de crier
j'ai le droit de taper vous ne me
connaissez pas je ne vous connais pas
vous n'avez rien à me dire euh donc on
est confronté quand même tous les jours
et même dans de très bons établissements
scolaires et évidemment que nous
intervenons euh nous ne fermons pas les
yeux devant les situation de bagarre ou
quand on voit un élève isolé euh ça ça
n'est pas du tout le propos en cependant
euh il est bien évident que moi je n'ai
reçu aucune formation de gestion
d'adolescents je je il y a des
compétences qu' les surveillants que je
n'ai pas euh puisque elles ne font pas
partie de de mes
attributions bon je me permets de
rebondir parce que c'est vrai que les
surveillants il y a surveillants et
surveillants il y a des surveillants ETL
qui n'ont aucune compétences non plus
parce que ce sont euh bah des des
personnes qui sont là parce que elles
ont aussi besoin de de travailler et
donc par contre il y a des personnes qui
ont des vraies compétences puisque bon
des CPE ont fait redescendre un certain
un nombre de surveillants j'allais dire
à l'ancienne hein voilà euh donc bon
c'est vrai que vous vous êtes professeur
et bon nous discutions en aparté tout à
l'heure je disais enseignante et maman
donc vous vous voyez aussi avec votre
œil
d'enseignante bah l'école maternelle
l'école donc tout le cursus scolaire et
donc par rapport euh à ce dont nous
traitons qui sont les les valeurs
républicaines le malaise des enseignants
et bien sûr la finalité étant l'école et
toute tout ce que l'on peut ou l'on doit
enseigner moi je voulais vous poser la
question un petit peu justement par
rapport éducation et enseignement hein
puisqu'on a aussi toujours est-ce que on
est là pour éduquer est-ce qu'on est là
pour enseigner euh par rapport bien sûr
à l'enseignement de la morale la Charte
de la laïcité euh je voulais avoir aussi
un petit peu votre avis avec cette
double casquette
et bien effectivement quand j'ai
commencé à renseigner je n'étais pas
maman je n'avais pas d'enfant et j'avais
j'étais sans doute beaucoup plus
exigeante avec mes élèves que je ne le
suis aujourd'hui ayant trois enfants un
garçon au collège et une petite à la
maternelle et une autre au primaire euh
mais je crois que je suis devenue
finalement plus exigeante avec mes
élèves sur le motif de l'éducation
c'est-à-dire les manières la politesse
c'estàd ne pas penser que le professeur
est un meuble et qu'on peut rentrer dans
la classe bruillamment sans le saluer
alors que je le fais beaucoup de mes
collègues aussi nous sommes à la porte
de notre classe et nous nous efforçons
de saluer nos élèves par leur prénom et
donc nous exigeons en retour qu'il nous
disent bonjour
madame tout comme lorsque la sonnerie
retentit il n'est pas question de ranger
ses affaires et de sortir avant que le
professeur ait même plus le temps de
finir sa phrase ou comme ça se fait dans
certains établissements mettre son
manteau sa capuche son sac bruillamment
et faire un décompte des 10 secondes
qu'il reste jusqu'à la onnerie
bruillamment donc tout ça ça s'apprend
et c'est à peu près un mois de mise en
place dans une classe pour dire voilà ce
MES exigence et en retour le professeur
et je crois que nous sommes nombreux à
le faire est lui-même toujours ponctuel
ayant fait son travail rendant les
copies dans un temps imparti qui soit
raisonnable s'adressant poliment à ses
élèves et je crois que les élèves ont
beaucoup de respect quand il ils voient
qu'en face d'eux l'enseignant est un
adulte sûr sur lequel on peut s'appuyer
et qui est professionnellement
irréprochable ce qui encore une fois est
vraiment le cas dans nos chez nos
collègues euh donc là je crois qu'on
peut instaurer un respect de l'adulte
qui passe par notre profession et qui
n'a pas besoin de de de corps et de
trompettes et petit à petit ça se met en
place et ça se met bien mais je crois
que beaucoup de collègues vous voient à
nouveau les élèves et beaucoup la
plupart de mes collègues ne commencent
pas leurs cours tant que les élèves ne
sont pas tous debout devant leur place
calme silencieux attendant que le
professeur donne la permission de
s'asseoir merci donc du coup le le
rapporteur Jacques gr Perin voulait
poser une autre question et mon collègue
Kenel aussi ex excuse-moi j'ai pas faire
attention juste par rapport à ça vous
parlez de Coret trompette je vais pas
faire référence à la chanson de Roland
mais mais certains certaines personnes
qui ont été auditionnées ici nous ont
dit
que les les la solution passerait par
euh par l'instruction euh par la
découverte des grandes œuvres euh par
l'amélioration de la culture euh quels
sont euh les les les les pas simplement
les sentiments mais les difficultés et
comment les vos vos collègues peuvent
justement gérer tant vous au niveau de
de l'enseignement du français euh les
grandes œuvres que que l'anignement de
l'histoire vous parliez euh dans
d'autres sur d'autres revues en tout cas
d'autres papiers que vous avez fait sur
le le le problème de la Choa et du
ricanement des élèves et puis de de
considération brutale est-ce qu'à un
moment donné les enseignants n'ont pas
tendance à éviter de parler de sujets
qui pourrait crisper et puis arriver à
est ce qu'on pourra appeler une certaine
forme de déculturation de de nos
élèves monsieur Kenel
oui par respect par mes collègues je
vais je vais éviter de radoter donc je
je parce qu'ils entendront tout le temps
la même chose simplement je vous pose
deux questions la la la première si les
élèves venaient dans vos cours en
collège et si maîtrisz la langue
française est-ce que vous auriez un
métier différent et et sous quelle forme
deème deè question pour faciliter le
travail de notre rapporteur Jacques
groperin est-ce que vous auriez deux
suggestions à faire à l'issue de notre
rapport et
lesquels là aussi sont des questions
question très vaste
merci un sujet c'est évidemment une
tentation que pourrait avoir notamment
les professeurs de lettres et de
d'histoire nous sommes les plus
exposés et de SVT et de sport avec des
récrimination bon alors ce sont toujours
les mêmes pourquoi le calendri on
nadopterait pas le calendrier de légir
pourquoi les garçons et les filles sont
ensemble en sport pourquoi on fait des
cours sur la reproduction
et en sciences nature
pourquoi on parle toujours des Juifs
pourquoi bon enfin c'est tout c'est
toujours la même chose quels que soient
les établissements que je traversé
c'était toujours les mêmes questions
alors le la stratégie de l'évitement
elle est vraiment je crois pour des
professeurs qui et il y en a qui sont en
grande détresse et qui se disent bon je
ne vais pas m'exposer plus et je
vais ne pas traiter cette partie du
programme pour me consacrer à d'autres
choses et on les comprend j'étais
moi-même dans des situations où
effectivement c'était tellement
difficile et on est tellement seul
finalement alors là pour le coup quand
on est face à 30 élèves qui sont contre
vous on se sent vraiment très isolé mais
je crois et je suis persuadée que au
contraire affronter ces grands sujets et
donner humainement son avis en tant que
professeur mais aussi en tant qu'être
humain et de dire que la souffrance
malheureusement est partagé par tout le
monde à travers les siècles que nul
peuple n'a été épargné ni par la guerre
ni ni par la réduction en esclavage et
qu'on ne peut pas comparer les
souffrances par rapport aux autres et
attribuer des gens des médailles à ceux
qui auraient plus souffert que d'autres
je crois que
l'Universit enseigner l'univers
l'universalité du mal ça apporte
beaucoup aussi d'apaisement aux élèves
en disant que aujourd'hui ceux-ci sont
pointés du doigt hier c'était d'autres
et l'histoire est un vaste
recommencement et ne voyons essayons
d'apprendre de ces de ces périodes
historiques difficiles comment on peut
mieux vivre aujourd'hui et non
pas se se contantonner à cette ce
récital de souffrance qui est horrible à
travers l'histoire évidemment euh
essayer de de trouver des solutions et
de proposer une espérance proposer un
moyen d'en sortir et de vivre ensemble
tout de même et je crois que notre pays
la France a toujours accueilli la
diversité a toujours eu des grands
hommes et des grandes femmes qui
venaient d'autres pays des gens qui
avaient souffert et qui pourtant sont
sont devenus des citoyens et c'est ceuxa
qu'il faut mettre en lumière et ne pas
perdre l'espoir euh à propos
de que serait mon métier si mes élèves
maîtrisaient parfaitement le
français lorsque j'étais moi-même
collégienne nous arrivions en classe de
collège avec des bases quand même très
solides en grammaire en orthographe et
bien souvent nos nos professeurs
n'avaient pas besoin d'y revenir
aujourd'hui nous avons des élèves en
face de nous qui ignore à peu près tout
de la grammaire et à peu près tout de
l'orthographe alors ce n'est pas que je
n'aime pas enseigner la grammaire à
l'orthographe ça fait partie de mon
métier mais j'aime aussi la littérature
et c'est vrai que je me régale à étudier
les grands textes et que j'aime parler
avec mes élèves ça n'est pas parce que
mes
élèves n'ont rien appris à l'école
primaire je travaille en collaboration
avec beaucoup d'instituteur et je vois
et je vois avec mes enfants aussi que
tout ce que je fais au collège a déjà
été fait et par parfois be de manière
beaucoup plus approfondie que ce que moi
j'ai le temps de faire et donc la
question c'est où passe ce savoir
comment se fait-il qu'on ne puisse pas
empiler hein c'est ce qu'on explique aux
élèves que on est comme dans un jeu de
construction il faudrait qu'on puisse
s'appuyer sur une base solide pour
mettre nos petites briqu année après
année voilà or on voit que il y a une
espèce d'émiettement des connaissances
que une espèce de de de de disparition
de ces acquis et je ne suis bien en
peine de vous dire pourquoi mais nous
devons
unlassablement mettre sur le métier
notre ouvrage et recommencer chaque
année des leçons qui sont barbantes
autant pour le professeur que le lève le
COD le COI par exemple alors que nous
savons parfaitement que tout le monde
l'a déjà appris avant alors mon métier
ne serait pas un métier idéal c'est pas
ce que je veux dire mais j'aimerais
consacrer plus de temps à la littérature
à l'étude des grands textes qu'à
expliquer invariablement l'accord du
participe passé à des élèves de 3è qui
n'y comprennent rien il y a quand même
un un petit problème euh à propos de
suggestion que je pourrais faire alors
là vraiment c'est c'est une question qui
est très
difficile c'est une question qui est
très difficile vous avez compris que les
difficultés sont énormes et vastes et
bon je parle en mon petit nom de je suis
une simple professeur certifiée de
français je n'ai pas toutes les
compétences de certains de mes collègues
beaucoup plus même que moi de répondre
mais nous
voudrions euh en premier lieu nous
voudrions plus de considération et pas
de la part de nos élèves qui en ont
beaucoup pour nous nos élèves nous
respectent nos élèves nous nous aiment à
la fin de l'année il y a des liens très
forts qu'il se tissent quand on
rencontre un ancien élève dans la rue
dans le métro vous ne pouvez pas vous
imaginer ce qu'on reçoit comme
humainement comme gratitude et comme
contact chaleureux et en revanche nous
avons l'impression que nous sommes
vraiment très maltaités par notre
hiérarchie mal considéré on nous parle
mal on s'adresse à nous de manière comme
si nous étions des je sais pas de de
vulgaires personnes qu'on peut nommer si
et là comme on veut imaginez-vous que
moi je suis sur trois établissements
cette année voilà donc je passe ma vie
dans les transports le matin dans un
établissement l'après-midi dans l'autre
je n'ai aucun espoir d'avoir l'année
prochaine un poste fixe je suis
enseignante depuis 15 ans donc vraiment
j'ai l'impression que on nous traite
d'une façon qui n'est qui est vraiment
je pense très décourageant pour certains
de nos collègues c'est pas tellement
vraiment encore une fois nos élèves qui
nous découragent dans cette profession
mais c'est le chemin qu'on nous propose
qui est d'abord obscur et auquel on ne
comprend pas grand-chose et la
considération le peu de considération
que nous avons pour notre
profession merci beaucoup nous avons
encore le temps d'une question madame
duchen excusez-moi je ne vous avais pas
vu et monsieur Carl il en redemande mais
vous avez le temps donc je vous
autoriserai aussi ma question va être
brève vous savez à plusieurs reprises
parler de 30 élèves devant
vous pensez-vous que si si vous n'en
aviez que entre guillemets que 20 est-ce
que vous pensez que ça pourrait résoudre
le problème j'en parle parce que sur le
plan financier bien sûr ça doit se
discuter mais comme nous
savions comme 60000 enseignants invités
choisis je me demande si la possibilité
de mettre moins de d'élèves dans
certains établissements faciliterait le
travail pour vous et un mil000 merci
pour votre témoignage si vrai voà merci
madame monsieur Carla oui merci madame
la Présidente vous nous avez dit que
150000 jeunes sortaient du collège moins
savant qu'il n'y étaient entrés ce sont
d'ailleurs les 150000 qui quittent le
système scolaire sans diplôme et sans
qualification qui coûte 36 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires à la
collectivité et et sur cette corord de
150000 moyen chiffre qui m'avait frappé
qui me frappe c'est que pour un sur de
ils avait soit redoublé soit eu
d'énormes difficultés dans le en CP CE1
ou CE2 ce qui montre bien la nécessité
hein de maîtriser les fondamentaux euh
très tôt est-ce que c'est pas là où il
faudrait que nous consacrons tous les
moyens nécessaires pour faire en sorte
que les acquis euh les fondamentaux soit
acquis très tôt parce que ensuite vous
disiez he ils sont acquis mais après ils
se
diluent oui parce qu'après la rue vient
concurrencer l'école et c'est toujours
la rue qui l'emporte tout à
fait sur sur la première question en ce
qui concerne le nombre d'élèves par
classe j'ai déjà enseigné dans des
classes où il y avait 18 élèves et
c'était vraiment très difficile parce
que là à 18 élèves vous n'avez pas
d'esprit de classe et c'est ça c'est pas
de en fait c'est une atmosphère qui est
très étrange et qui est peu propice en
fait à à à l'enseignement
euh en principe en ZEP les classes sont
limité à 24 donc j'ai travaillé
longtemps en ZEP et c'est vrai que quand
on avait la chance d'avoir ce dispositif
parce que c'est de moins en moins le cas
24 25 amudi gliani cette année j'ai 26
élèves dans ma classe et c'est très
agréable voilà je pense que c'est un
maximum et c'est pour des élèves de
collège après en lycée on peut j'ai j'ai
enseigné en lycée avec 38 39 élèves par
classe mais c'est tout à fait différent
parce que le public est beaucoup plus
calme
euh 32 élèves en collège c'est beaucoup
trop cette année au lycée Victor durui
en collège ils avaient 39 élèves à la
rentrée par classe euh ça n'est pas
possible là vous on se heurte à des
difficultés qui ne sont pas maîtrisables
donc il y a un juste milieu je crois que
effectivement le 24 25 26 élèves c'est
parfait mais moins 20 20 20 élèves par
exemple je pense que ce n'est pas assez
pour faire une classe en ce qui concerne
l'âge des apprentissages je suis je
partage absolument votre point de vue je
crois qu'effectivement il y a un âge
pour être professeur et maman ou qui est
tout dévoué tout dédié à l'apprentissage
âge et cet âge là on le sait très bien
c'est 5 6 7 ans c'est exactement les
classes de CP et de CE1 et le travail
qui n'est pas accompli dans ces
années-là est perdu pour toujours parce
que moi je reçois des élèves en 6e 5e
qui n'ont pas les fondamentaux et je
peux passer des heures avec eux ça
n'imprimera pas de la même façon sur
leur cerveau que ça l'aurait ça aurait
dû le faire quand ils étaient petits
après les causes sont multiples il y a
des des des cassures chez les enfants dû
à des déménagements des séparations des
guerre pour certains nous avons dans nos
classes nous avons reçu dans nos classes
à l'occasion de ce grave conflit qu'il y
avait en Côte d'Ivoire de la guerre
civile beaucoup d'élèves qui sont
arrivés fracassés parce qu'ils avaient
vu et qu'on nous a mis dans les classes
sans s de décompression en s'imaginant
que l'école française est tellement
magique que nous allions faire des
miracles je ne sais pas m'adresser un
enfant soldat et ça m'est difficile de
lui expliquer pourquoi on ne peut pas
taper sur son camarade parce que il vous
a juste effleuré avec son coude euh donc
effectivement là quand c'est cassé on
voit bien que c'est trop tard au collège
c'est déjà trop tard alors au lycée n'en
parlons pas et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec votre proposition de
mettre beaucoup de moyens sur ces
petites classes soulager nos collègues
de l'école primaire qui ont des classes
extrêmement chargé aussi et peu de temps
à consacrer à chacun de ses enfants ou
alors c'est du temps en plus entre MIDH
et 2 à la pause méridienne pour des
enfants qui ont besoin de de sortir de
s'aérer de déjeuner donc effectivement
il y a là je crois qu'il un grand
travail à accomplir avec nos collègues
instituteurs qui font et vous le savez
on le sait tous un travail
exceptionnel merci
beaucoup c'est bon tout le monde a eu
ses réponses donc je vous remercie parce
que je crois que petit à petit au fur à
mesure de cette commission d'enquête on
voit un certain nombre de choses et des
des choses qui reviennent
régulièrement moins d'élèves en petite
classe ou ou deux enseignants ou voilà
mais je crois qu' est d'accord sur les
bases et donc d'un côté les fondamentaux
de l'autre les règles de vie la
politesse et tout ça pour arriver à des
valeurs républicaines et et de
citoyenneté merci
beaucoup voilà pour ces auditions sur le
thème de l'éducation et la perte de
repères républicains la commission
d'enquête sur ce sujet au Sénat recevait
donc deux enseignants qui revenaient sur
leurs expériences et les difficultés
rencontrées dans le cadre de leurs
métier ils ont livré au sénateur leur
vision de l'école la commission
d'enquête sur ce sujet continue ses
auditions des auditions que vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires